اضربوا عمال النظافه في باريس احتجاجا على
رفع سن التقاعد يضع اشهر عواصم العالم تحت
اكوام من النفايات اكثر من خمسه الاف طن
من النفايات تراكمت في باريس وسط تحذيرات
من تفاقم الازمه
من كان يتخيل يوما ان ياتي الى باريس
لاستكشاف انواع العطور او حتى الاستمتاع
بسحر الابنيه والشوارع ليجد نفسه محاصرا
وسط اكوام من القمامه ورائحه كريهه اصحاب
المطاعم والعمال هؤلاء يقومون بازاله
القمامه من امام مطاعمهم لانها اثرت على
اعمالهم بشده بيروت ما كانت هيك يعني
بايامتها لكل المطاعم يعني ما بعرف شو بدي
اقول
الزباله والروائح بتطلع كيف العالم بدها
تيجي تاكل بس
ولكن بيروت احسن
وهيدي كومه الزباله شلناها
اصحاب المطاعم قرروا التحرك بمفردهم على
امل ان تقوم البلديه بازاله اكوام القمامه
هذه العمليه ستتواصل طوال فتره ما بعد
الظهر سنقوم برش ماء الجافيل والتنظيف
بانتظار ان تاتي بلديه باريس وتاخذ كل هذه
القمامه اتمنى ان ينتهي هذا الاضطراب لكن
هذه المبادره لم ترق لبعض السكان الذين
اعتبروا انها لا تحل المشكله بل تقذفها
امام بيوت اناس اخرين لا ذنبلهم بما يحصل
هذا ليس امرا مقبولا ان تقوم المطاعم بنقل
نفاياتها امام ابنيه السكان انا ايضا لدي
قمامه لكن لن اقوم بالقائها امام مباني
الاخرين لاتخلص منها
وفادي يبقى معي من باريس للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع فادي اهلا وسهلا بك هل من حل او
حلول مطروحه لحل ازمه النفايات المتراكمه
في العاصمه الفرنسيه ام لا الامور ذاهبه
الى مزيد من التصعيد والتازم
اهلا طالب الامور ذاهبه الى مزيد من
التصعيد لان العمال صوتوا اليوم على تمديد
اضرابهم حتى يوم الاثنين المقبل كان من
المفترض ان ينتهي هذا الاضراب يوم غد
الاربعاء لكنهم صوتوا اليوم على تمديده
حتى يوم الاثنين المقبل حقيقه هذا الاضراب
هو اكبر حركه او اهم حركه اضراب لجامعي
القمامه في العشرين سنه الماضيه في باريس
اهميتها تاتي من انها من السياق الحالي في
فرنسا مع مساعد الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما وايضا لانه يشمل مدن عديده
ليس باريس وحدها وانما نامت
ومدن كثيره اخرى كذلك الوضع الاسوء كما
ترون هو في باريس العاصمه تعيش تحت ما
يقرب من 6000 طن اليوم بحسب اخر التحديثات
التي اصدرتها بلديه باريس وايضا كان هناك
فيديو مسرب بدا ينشر يوم امس على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
لاكوان من القمامه على مدخل قصر الرئاسه
الفرنسيه في
طبعا هذا الاضراب كما ذكرت سوف يتواصل الى
يوم الاثنين المقبل وبعض البلديات في
محاوله لايجاد حلول بدء التجه الى القوه
لرفع القمامه من خلال ان تقوم باجبار
الموظفين المضربين على ان ياتوا للعمل
ويرفع هذه الاكوان من القمامه استنادا الى
بعض المواد القانونيه التي تصدر عن
المحاكم ويتم ابلاغهم بها من خلال مراكز
الشرطه نحن الان نسير في احد الشوارع في
الدائره الثامنه في باريس وهي احدى ارقى
المناطق في العاصمه باريس طبعا ايضا يوم
غد سيكون هناك تحرك احتجاجي جديد اليوم
قياده شرطه باريس اصدرت امرا لبلديه
العاصمه بالتحرك من اجل ازاله هذه
الاكوان من مسار التظاهره المرتقبه غدا
حتى لا يستفيد منها المتظاهرون لاشعالها
وافتعال الحوادث مع عناصر الشرطه طب فادي
خيارات الحكومه خيارات
حكومه رئيس ماكرون في حال استمرت النقابات
بالاضراب يعني البعض طرح انه ان تستعين
الحكومه بشركات خاصه لرفع النفايات ما هي
خيارات الحكومه يعني هل من حديث من هذا
القبيل في هذه المرحله
صحيح طالب هناك بعض البلديات تستفيد من
وجود شركات خاصه لجمع القمامه لكن الصعوبه
اليوم هي انه حتى عمال المحارق ومعامل
الفرز والتدوير يشتركون في هذه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه لذلك هناك معامل ضخمه جدا
تابعه لشركه سكتو على سبيل المثال في
افريسورسين وسانتوان وايضا في هذه المناطق
كلها مغلقه الان بسبب حركه الاضراب وحتى
الشركات الخاصه لا تتمكن من ان
تقوم بوضع هذه الاكوان من القمامه في تلك
المعامل السيناريو الوحيد حتى الان هو ان
تقوم البلديات باستدعاء افراد الامن
المدني لازاله هذه الاكوان وهذا الامر حصل
في عام 2003 على سبيل المثال في مدينه
شمال فرنسا
ايضا حصل في مدينه مارسيليا جنوب البلاد
كان هناك اكثر من عشره الاف طن من القمامه
تمكنوا من رفعها من خلال هذا الامر طيب من
باريس مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك فادي
على كل هذه المتابعه